so what I'm speculating is what if
someone says okay well Elon has the
platform now let's talk about how many
Bots are on the platform oh it's it's 50
of the platform and if people it's a
private company so it's not subject to
the same sort of security but someone
could leak or or try to of course
sabotage the company yeah I mean maybe
but it's it the the the sort of obvious
methods of sabotage that you're thinking
of wouldn't work in the world where it's
a private company and then it doesn't
have to obey Securities laws in the same
way right where it's you know the it's
it's one of the big disciplining things
about our system and and I think people
you know we think that the free market
and capitalism only you know works
because of competition but one big thing
is that public company CEOs have to tell
the truth about their companies every
three months in a way that politicians
don't yeah you know politicians can just
lie and lie and lie about the operation
of the government and so can the
department heads and nobody goes
nobody's ever you know threatened with
jail for that but if you are a public
company CEO and you lie about your
business results you can go to jail for
Securities fraud